ou demain l'Irlande le sang a coulé à
London Derry hier après-midi rien ne le
laissaer prévoir c'était un dimanche
comme tant d'autres dimanches il y avait
une manifestation de jeunes catholiques
comme il y en a eu tant ettant depuis 4
ans depuis 68 depuis la reprise de la
violence dans cette province britannique
un cortège de jeunes catholiques
Bernadette develin en tête l'armée en
face et puis soudainement c'est le drame
ce qui s'est passé hier nous rappelle à
nous Français à plus d'un titre les
pires heures de l'Algérie la fusillade
de la rue d'li en mars 1962 notamment ce
qui ne veut pas dire que lulster va
maintenant trouver son indépendance les
images que nous envoie la BBC commenté
par George
P pour les catholiques ce dimanche est
presque un jour de fête du moins c'est
comme ça que cela commence tout commence
dans le calme est un jeu alors que les
catholiques brav l'interdit qui depuis
plusieurs semaines pè sur toutes les
manifestations qu'ell soit catholique ou
protestante ce dimanche ils sont 10000
peut-être 20000 la marche est organisée
pour protester contre l'internement
administratif c'est-à-dire l'arrestation
arbitraire des gens jugés
dangereux il est à peu près 3h de
l'après-midi aucun heure avec les forces
de l'ordre pour
[Musique]
l'instant et puis brusquement les heur
éclatent il est 3h30 à peu près de
l'après-midi les catholiques ont voul
emprunter une route une rue interdite
par l'armée lapide le service
[Musique]
d'ordre le face à face dure 10 minutes à
peu
près et puis c'est l'assut l'assut donné
par les
troupes
des engins blindés et des hommes du
premier bataillon du régiment de
parachutiste des hommes apparemment
effrayés par cette
[Musique]
tâche à 4h de l'après-midi on na pas
encore tiré puis à 4h5 un premier coup
de feu on ne sait pas qui a tiré
l'armée réplique il y a 13 morts par bal
et 50 ou 60
[Musique]
blessés
qui a tiré le premier on ne sait pas les
officiers anglais affirment que des fr
tireurs ont commencé par tirer
les témoins irlandais et en tête
Bernadette accuse ce F un massacre et
simple l' sur tout ce qui
[Musique]
bouge
that
out le jeune député catholique
Bernadette develine vient de partir pour
Londres elle demande une réunion
extraordinaire du Parlement on ne sait
pas qui a commencé ce que l'on connaît
c'est le nombre total des victimes en
Irlande du Nord en 4 années de violence
231 morts et ce matin à belfaste je
vlais signaler en commençant ce journal
ce matin commencent les représailles
prévu par l'IRA l'armée républicaine
irlandaise trois attentats à la bombe
l'un de ces attentats a fait 10 blessés
une forte charge d'explosif à éclaté
dans un magasin en plein cœur de Belfast
voilà donc où on en est triste Irlande
triste début semaine triste suite d'un
conflit quand finira-t-il